bonjour bonjour bonjour ça va ça va et
toi très bien ouais depuis la dernière
fois bah ouais ça fait qu un an et demi
peêtre ouais un peu plus ou un peu plus
d'un an peut-être bienvenue merci merci
merci on a une petite vue sympa j'ai vu
ça c'est dingue ici il me semble que
c'est l'observateire de la la SB qui est
làb en plus oua superbe just sympathique
trop bien tu vas aller te maquiller
allez on va se maquiller toi tu es déjà
passé Mo moi c'est déjà fait c'est toi
tu tu passes ta vie maquillée c'est ça
c'est ça je me démaquille jamais il y en
a plein sur les oreillers un peu plus de
temps en France ces derniers jours ou
non quoi que çaou Mme si si un peu le
plus gros du temps c'est où quand quand
tu es en repos
tu c'est plutôt Cologne j'essaie de de
passer du temps là-bas c'est là que je
suis le plus tranquille en plus comme
personne me reconnaiss tellement ch unre
cadre je vais faire mes cours trop bien
Paris tu te balades faire tes courses
sera pas le même ouais mais je le fais
d'ailleurs je vais faire mes courses à
Paris je bien avoir la tête des ouais
les gens disent mais qu'est-ce que vous
faites là comme vous j'achète des yaourt
c'est bon merci c'est beaucoup mieux
qu'avant merci bien
joué
bonjour Thomas Pesquet bonjour Hugo ravi
d'échanger ensemble tu es prêt ouais je
suis prêt on peut partir du
coup la planète un symbole planète alors
il y a quelques jours en fait en
préparant cette discussion là je suis
tombé sur un quiz qui consistait à
reconnaître des lieux ça peut être une
ville un pays un lieu connu à partir
d'une photo vue du ciel tu connais mieux
que personne la Terre vue du ciel je te
propose qu'on essaie de jouer ensemble
ok en 60 secondes tu V essayer d'en
trouver un maximum d'accord soit tu le
trouves si tu le trouves pas tu peux
dire passe il y en aura d'autres
derrière et on va essayer de voir
combien tu peux en trouver ok tu es prêt
ouais c'est parti c'est parti allez bon
Paris de
tri ça c'est est-ce que c'est
l'embouchure de la Méditerranée avec
ouais des TR Gibraltar des TR Gibraltar
ok là on a les pyramides enfin c'est les
avec les pyramides avec le Nili là mon
SaintMichel facile ça
ouais ça je je sais pas ça ressemble un
peu peut-être à l'Amérique du Sud mais
je sais pas ouais c'est c'est l'Amazone
la suivante la suivante écoute ça c'est
de nuit ah c'est la Corée du Nord la
Corée du Sud c'est qui est là et puis
onang la petite tche ex la différence
des d'éclairage qu'on voit la suivante
la suivante c'est le Palm jumera c'est
Dubaï la suivante la suivante ça c'est
ran je crois oui très bien ça ça
t'évoque quelque chose ouais ça c'est la
botte l'Italie il a Rome Naple les
Pouilles celle-ci peut-être un peu plus
compliqué ou là celle-ci c'est un peu
chaud paysage de
montagne de Chine peut-être ouais
exactement très fort parfait pour
l'instant ok ici qu'est-ce qu'on a
ouais non ça je sais pas je dirais Asie
du Sud-Est ouais c'est le Japon et une
dernière peut-être ici
ça je dirais dans les dans les pays qui
finissent en ce temp enfin dans les
hautes kirgistan et C exactement
effectivement la dernière photo celle
qu'on voit ici c'est la mer d'Aral et
c'est une photo donc là il y avait un
petit piège c'est une photo qui date de
2000 je précise du coup 2000 parce que
effectivement aujourd'hui ça ressemble
pas du tout à ça ça ressemble pas du
tout à ça ça ressemble plutôt à ça
ouais on voit la différence frappante en
en une vingtaine d'années pour le
contexte à l'époque c'était le 4e plus
grand lac de la planète sauf que les
autorités ont détourné une partie des
fleuves pour irriguer leur culture donc
ont privé ce lac d'eau est-ce que tu as
pu voir de ton côté les conséquences de
l'activité humaine sur sur la planète
ouais on voit ça ouais on voit la
pollution on voit la pollution des
rivières des embouchures des grandes
villes on voit la pollution de l'air on
voit les couples dans la forêt
amazonienne surtout ce qu'on voit moi je
trouve c'est les les phénomènes
climatiques extrêmes qui se renforcent
tous les étés on a des mégafeu alors
c'est pas forcément toujours en France
heureusement mais c'est en Méditerranée
c'est au Canada ça clairement ça
augmente et tu le vois l'œ nu et c'est
super impressionnant et on est parfois
même activé dans la station spatiale par
le centre de contrôle quand il y a une
catastrophe quelque part et que on peut
avoir bah une une orbite qui va nous la
faire survoler et que ça peut peut-être
aider les services de secours au sol ou
les gens qui ont envie de comprendre ce
qui se passe qui ont envie d'aider et
donc on l'a sur l'emploi du temps et on
essaie de faire notre mieux évidemment B
pour documenter faire des photos
renvoyer aux gens qui ont essayer de de
faire face à tout ça on va pouvoir voir
la la question suivante rejouer allez
c'est parti les symboles je te laisse
appuyer j'ai toujours rêvé de faire ça
alors on va voir sur quoi ça tombe là
c'est en locurence c'est un symbole
enveloppe courrier un message du coup va
va s'afficher derrière ce symbole c'est
un email donc je t'invite si tu veux à
lire à V salut mon vionix ça fait
plaisir de te lire ici dans l'espace
tout roule tê dans le Guillon toute la
journée auord de Mission Control mais un
peu de temps le soir pour regarder par
la fenêtre et faire quelques vol
acrobatiqu en cabine il y a quelques
virages que je prends un peu trop à fond
j'ai déjà quelques crashes au compteur
mais ça passe je vous fais des bises à
tous et à la proxima Thomas et justement
donc ce fameux Nyx donc Nicolas son son
vrai nom c'est un de tes meilleurs amis
et quand on lui a dit que on allait te
te recevoir il a proposé de de te
laisser un petit message une petite
vidéo donc on va pouvoir laavir tout de
suite salut Tom Tom alors ça y est tu
racontes ta vie bah écoute c'est une
super idée parce que ta vie elle est
super inspirante en tout cas moi tu m'as
toujours inspiré depuis 25 ans qu'on se
connaît dans toutes nos péripéties tu es
toujours celui qui féère et puis aussi
celui qui apaise les situations qui
calme le jeu et je sais que on en a eu
parfois des situations avec des mecs
assez énervés merci pour tout on est
super fier de toi continue de nous faire
rêver et puis même si M maintenant tu tu
vises la lune la vraie question c'est
quand même quand est-ce qu'on l'a fait
cette transat avec wendal allez la bise
et à très vite pour la suite des
aventures trop bien il parle de faire
une
transatlantique il parle aussi du fait
de viser la lune quand tu as des
objectifs aussi importants d'un point de
vue professionnel comment tu as Arve à
concilier une vie pro et une vie perso
est-ce que c'est jouable déjà bah c'est
difficile ouais c'est difficile c'est
pas c'est pas un un emploi très family
friendly de d'être astronaute c'est
c'est sûr donc non c'est difficile de
trouver sa place il y a du risque aussi
tu sais les gens ils ont peur pour toi
en vrai quelque part on a on en parle
pas trop parce que on a pas envie d'en
parler tu vois on dit toujours non mais
t'inquiète pas tout va bien se passer
tout va bien se passer mais à un moment
tu as envie de parler du du cas où ça se
passe mal si tu veux attends laissez-moi
un peu parler de ma peur et c'est vrai
que il y a pas trop de place pour ça
parfois ça peut être difficile ouais ça
pose la question de la solitude quand tu
es aussi loin aussi haut pendant aussi
longtemps alors certes tu es pas tout
seul dans la station spatiale
international mais il y a pas forcément
tes
proches comment on affronte la solitude
il faut être occupé en fait parce que
quand tu as rien à faire la station
spatiale c'est un peu une prison avec
une belle vue tu vois c'est pas la
prison évidemment je compare pas mais
mais tu vois tu es tu es quand même
enfermé dans un truc tu tournes en ça
reste un lieu qui est relativement petit
voà et et en plus plus tu as du temps
plus tu parles à ta famille plus tu plus
il te manque plus tu vois que je sais
pas ta petite fille grandit fait ses
premiers pas et cetera alors que dès que
dès que tu as du boulot et que tu es à
fond la casse et ben là tuas tuas un peu
moins le loisir de de te laisser aller
on va passer à la question suivante je
relance cette petite roue de de symbole
je change ma technique peut-être que ça
a changer le ça va changer le résultat
c'est un 10/ 10
te c'est un symbole tableau on a mis la
main sur quelque chose oh là là je c je
crains le pire c'est mes notes ça
tu dates de CM1 oh la
honte attends mais il y a pas que des
10/ 10 et des 20 sur 20 alors non alors
je précise quand même il y a beaucoup de
sur 10 là a seulement heureusement c'est
marqué sur 10 9/ 10 9/ 10 8 et demi sur
10 bon ça va plutôt solide ouais c'est
ad admis en CM2 c'était quoi la matière
avec le recul la matière la plus
importante en cours pour faire ce que tu
fais aujourd'hui ah ça c'est une c'est
une question difficile tu sais je pense
que ce qui est la vraie réponse à ça
c'est pas que j'essaie de de te faire
une réponse de Normand mais mais c'est
que quelque part tout était un petit peu
important c'est vrai hein tu vois bon je
fais un métier scientifique et technique
c'est certain mais j'ai pas eu besoin
d'être prix Nobel de de physique donc il
faut pas mettre tous ses X dans le même
panier tu vois aujourd'hui la partie où
je partage ma mission bah évidemment il
faut savoir un peu écrire lire et cetera
la géographie on vient de le voir c'est
quand même un peu important tu vois tous
les trucs ont été important l'anglais
les langues étrangères je t'en parle
même pas prier c'est pas qu' prof
scientifique il faut il faut un peu tout
c'est c'est quand même intéressant à à
voir et il y a des profes justement qui
t'ont marqué particulièrement que ce
soit dans les sciences au lycée ou autre
ouais il y en a eu alors j'ai beaucoup
de c'est c'est fou mais j'ai pas mal de
souvenirs de de plein de
profs il y en a eu plein j'ai mon prof
de mat de lycée qui s'appelle monsieur
Capel qui qui est vraiment un des
premiers qui qui m'a fait comprendre un
peu la rigueur scientifique tu sais que
les maths c'était pas juste on rigole
avec
c'était
ah bah très bien ça va bonjour Thomas
bon B là c'est pas vous on est d'accord
que c'était pas triché on c'était pas
triché on l'a pas on l' pas moi je
savais il était pas de passageci je
savis il était comment Thomas Pesquet
enfour Thomas c'était quelqu'un de
discret d'une part et extrêmement
agréable comme élève il se mettait pas
en avant je pense qu'il était bien
apprécié de tous ses camarades il me
semble honnêtement je trouvais aussi que
alécrit il était extrêmement clair si
bien que quand tu faisais une faute on
la voyait
clairement mais il avait une très bonne
rédaction c'est le souvenir que j'ai
gardé de toi une il rédigeait très très
clairement et il exprimait très
clairement ses idées et quand on te
revoit dans tes dans tes interventions
tu es toujours très pédagogue tu avais
ça en toi je pense dès le début ouais ce
que je vous propose c'est qu'on essaie
de résoudre ensemble un
problème un problème pouvoir prendre ta
vche de logique résoudre tout ça oh on a
un tableau et on a tout ça est très bien
fait des ardoises toi tu as une table
numérique mais tu as des ardoises en
fait c'est ça vraiment on jou sur tous
les table tous les tableau oui si Thomas
tu veux lire l'énoncé peut-être pour
ouais on a cinq fusées A C D ok se
dirige vers Mars à des vitesses
différentes et constantes quelle fusée
arrive la première
bon ça va alors la fusée a voyage à une
vitesse deux fois inférieure à celle de
la fusée B la fusée B une vitesse égale
à la somme des vitesses des fusées B + E
la fusée c est trois fois inférieure à
celle de la fusée B et la fusée d voyage
à une vitesse 4re fois inférieur à celle
de la fusée e et la fusée e une vitesse
inférieure à celle de la fusée
a on VO les calcules alors en fait je
cherche à voir si tout de suite rien
qu'en lisant le le raisonnement vois la
plus rapide donc je vois que A est moins
rapide que B donc pour l'instant B c'est
la plus rapide B est aussi plus rapide
que d donc pour l'instant B c'est t la
plus rapide c'est TR fois inf
d FO inférieur à E mais d est forcément
inférieur à B et E inférieur à a qui est
déjà inférieur à B donc en lisant
l'énoncé on sait que c'est B la plus
rapide en lisant
l'céais dit que tu allais
prendre ouais finalement après après des
années ça est merci beaucoup
félicitations félicitations non mais je
je jeis pas très étonné c'était pas le
plus dur non plus il m'en a sorti des
plus durs dans ma
carrière mon dans la station spaale
internationale ouou voà c'est ça on
rassure on rassure tous les candidats là
avec ça merci beaucoup monsieur Capel
merci d'avoir acéir pour moi venir céit
génial merci Thomas grand plaisir
merci c'est une petite surprise oui
voilà s'il y a tous les profs et qu'il
faut faire l'anglais la géographie la
physique tout ça ça va quand même être
non mais ça me fait plaisir mais ce que
je disais tout à l'heure j'ai beaucoup
de reconnaissance les gens comme
Monsieur Capel il y en a d'autres he
prof d'anglais prof de mais on passe à
la question suivante allez allez
sablier on a dé on a déjà fait sablier
c'eston l'utilise beaucoup aujourd'hui
c'est un accessoire quand même assez
utile alors le principe est très simple
ok le sablier va s'écouler pendant 60
secondes ouais et pendant 60 secondes tu
vas devoir répondre un maximum de
questions par oui par non ou passer si
tu veux passer sur une question mais
jeis te posé un maximum de questions en
une minute ok c'est vrai ouais je suis
prêt est-ce que tu en as marre qu'on te
présente comme l'homme idéal oui si tu
n'avais pas été astronaute est-ce que tu
serais resté pilote de
ligne sans doute est-ce que ça sent bon
dans l'ISS non est-ce que tu es déjà
tombé malade dans l'espace non tu crois
aux extraterrestres h oui mais faut
développer et l'astrologie est-ce que tu
y crois pas du tout marcher sur la lune
est-ce que c'est un objectif oui
l'argent fait-il le bonheur non est-ce
que tu es optimiste pour l'avenir oui tu
étais bon en art plastique à l'école non
on a trouvé une faille ça tangoisse le
temps qui passe pas encore être
astronaute et avoir une famille est-ce
que c'est compatible non 6 mois à bord
de l'ISS est-ce que ça te semblait long
non tu prends des stagiaires avec toi
dans l'ISS non être astronaute et écolo
est-ce que c'est possible oui est-ce que
le chinois c'est plus dur à apprendre
que le Russe oui le monond Saint-Michel
c'est en Normandie oui on ira sur Mars
un jour oui et dernière question un
chinois sur la lune est-ce que c'est
possible un jour oui et j'ai j'ai j'ai
puuisé toutes les questions
tu as été très bon mais la question des
des des extraterrestres évidemment c'est
c'est dur de d'y répondre oui al c'est
les extraterrestres c'est pas les petits
hommes verts si tu veux mais la vie dans
l'espace on s'interdit pas de penser que
ça peut exister ailleurs sous forme
bactérienne sous forme tu vois il y a
pas de raison qu'on soit unique au monde
il y a des des exoplanètes il y en a des
milliers c'est pas des milliards donc
voilà et on et on va faire des missions
d'ailleurs sur Europa qui est une lune
de Jupiter pour justement on sait qu'il
y a de l'eau il y a une couche de glace
il y a de l'eau en dessous on a vu des
gzer d'eau on pense qu'il y a peut-être
des trucs à trouver on va passer à la
question suivante je relance cette
petite roue de de
symbole c'est très bien alors c'est quoi
c'est une checklist c'est une liste
c'est un symbole ouais questionnaire
checklist on va voir tout ça en fait
derrière ça il y a une question à choix
multiple qui va apparaître à l'écran ok
je te préviens d'avance je te demande
pas d'y répondre tu vas voir pourquoi
mais si tu veux le lire à voix haute
d'accord dans une situation choisissez-
vous de sauvez en premier votre mère
votre père vous-même donc c'est le genre
de question c'est pour devenir
astronaute au sein de Lesa on est
d'accord ouais questionnaire de 1200
questions c'est quand même un petit
question costaud oua c'est un petit un
petit rythme l'idée c'est quoi avec ce
genre de question c'est de tester la
fiabilité d'une personne et en même
temps avec une question comme ça c'est
ultra complexe non c'est c'est on teste
plutôt alors je pense qu'il y a des des
aspects de personnalité évidemment si on
est un gros psychopathe je pense que ça
va se voir je pense que ce qu'on teste
aussi beaucoup c'est les gens qui
essayent de se de se construire un
profil en fait parce que souvent quand
on répond à une quand on une question
comme ça dans un contexte de sélection
on peut se dire voilà c'est c'est quoi
ma réponse naturelle et puis c'est quoi
la bonne réponse qu'ils ont envie
d'entendre tu vois tout le monde
fonctionne comme ça et je pense que
l'idée d'avoir tant de questions et qui
se recoupe tellement c'est que c'est
impossible de toujours donner la bonne
réponse et ça va se voir et la la raison
pour laquelle je dis ça c'est parce que
suite à ça on a eu à la phase suivante
de la sélection un entretien avec un
psychologue qui m'a dit je m'en rappelle
parce que ça m'a surpris je suis rentré
dans la salle bonjour monsieur pesqu me
dire alors vous vous êtes celui qui nous
avveait le moins menti alors que pour
moi j'ai eu l'impression de beaucoup
mtir c'est pas mais apparemment sur 1200
questions je m'étais pas beaucoup
contredit tu vois ce qui est pas le cas
de des gens général jeux de fiabilité
parmi les étapes de sélection donc il y
a des choses comme comme ces questions à
chat multiplle il y a aussi des tests
médicaux oui et on peut pas devenir
astronaut si on a déjà eu des caris par
exemple racontesou ouis c'est vrai alors
des caris c'est vrai que je le dis comme
ça après je crois que c'est plutôt des
plombages mais bon en général ça va
ensemble enfin je sais pas pourquoi
parce que quand on a une
dépressurisation justement c'est comme
dans un cockpit d'avion et que la
pression soudainement baisse et que à
l'intérieur de cavité qu'on peut avoir
bah notamment dans les dents parce que
elle reste la même parce qu'elle a pas
eu le temps de de baisser de s'égaliser
ben ça fait un peu bouchon de champagne
et on a on a les plombages qui peuvent
sauter donc on imagine on est en train
de faire face à une situation d'urgence
et tout d'un coup paf un truc énorme
douleur donc c'est un peu une
contreindication si vous voulez monter
dans l'ISS attention à votre dentition
attention à votre dentition voilà le
français l'anglais la géographie les
matths et brosser les dents plus
sérieusement ça montre quand même
quelque chose c'est que il y a
évidemment tout un tas de tests à tout
point de vue et on en a vu quelquesuns
ici il y a aussi des choses qui sont
parfois de l'URE du hasard faut dire moi
j'ai mon père a une très bonne vue ma
mère un peu moins moi j'ai une très
bonne vue mon frère un peu moins tu vois
donc déjà le loto de de la génétique il
y a rien à faire si tu veux moi j'ai eu
le le bon âge au bon moment mais j'ai
pas eu de problème de santé j'ai une
santé plutôt plutôt robuste je touche du
bois évidemment mais mais
ouais il y a une par de chance
incroyable et il y a l'histoire de il me
semble une anecdote d'un d'un niikola
tikonov je suis pas sûr de bien le
prononcer mais un brillant cosmonaute
qui a vu tous ses sacrifices et son
travail partir en fumée quelques mois
avant son décollage à cause d'une
branche dans l'œil je crois pendant
pendant un jogging ouais c'est ça les
sacrifice que tu fais des fois ça ça
paye pas lui il était CIT le plus jeune
de sa promotion d'astronaute hyper
brillant un mec super il a été assigné
sur une mission en dernier parce que
c'était le plus jeune finalement ensuite
les choses ont changé les Russes sont
passés de trois cosmonautes à deux dans
la St station il a été décalé plusieurs
fois comme ça finalement il était
doublur d'un équipage il devait partir 6
mois après ce lancement s'est mal passé
finalement il allait il allait voler
après je sais pas 13 ou 15 ans de
d'effort et de sacrifice et là jogging
avec son chien dans la forêt une branche
dans l'œil terminé visite médicale
perdue il ira jamais dans l'espace c'est
horrible c'est forcment très bien c'est
c'est tragique c'est tragique on va
passer à Alle question
suivante le coup de fil un ami euh non é
incroyable mais c'est c'est quasiment ça
parce qu'on a qu même un téléphone en
fait on a reçu forcément beaucoup de
questions quand on a annoncé que tu
allais tu allais venir beaucoup de
questions notamment sur la vie à bord de
la Station spatiale internationale ouis
ce que je te propose c'est que tu
prennes le téléphone il y a quatre
questions tu les écoutes et tu vas
pouvoir y répondre allez c'est
parti coucou Thomas j'ai juste une
petite question que je me pose depuis
longtemps il se passe quoi si quelqu'un
meurt dans lesisss ouais alors ça
commence direct avec les ouis légère si
quelqu'un meurt dans l'ISS c'est qu'il
s'est passé quelque chose de de
tellement énorme parce que nous on est
testé médicalement nous tout est testé
donc tu vois il y a pas de procédure
standard mais on a quand même des
éléments de de réaction tu vois on a un
défibrillateur on a des intraosseuses
des intraveineuses on a tout ce qu'
faudrait pour réagir à une situation
d'urgence après une fois que la
situation est finie et que j'espère que
non le le gars ou la fille est vraiment
plus de ce monde bon bah là il faudrait
je sais pas tellement ce qu'on ferait
c'est pas encore prévu c'est pas encore
tellement prévu ouais merci pour cette
question très joyeuse HUG très légère je
vous ai pas la poser donc quelqu'un
d'autre tu as raison c'est ça que tu
fais en fait ah l'excuse c'est une
question qui vient de quelqu'un je je
ouou je j'ai rien à voir avec ça je me
désolidarise totalement ok salut Thomas
je me demandais comment tu vas aux
toilettes dans l'ISS et après ça va où
est-ce que genre tout pars dans l'espace
non tu pars pas dans l'espace tu non en
fait ça marche par aspiration tu as un
espèce de tuyau avec une un anentau noir
au bout tu branches une dépression qui
se crée tu fais pipi dedans et ça se ça
se recycle et comme disait mon collègue
américain le café du jour devient le
café du
lendemain c'est une manière jolie de le
dire tu vois et pour le reste pour la
partie plutôt solide on va dire là on a
on a rien à faire tout un système pour
que ça soit un peu contrôlé mais en gros
on le
stock et puis on le met dans nos
véhicules cargo tu sais quand ils vont
brûler dans l'atmosphère avec nos
déchets en fait comme ça qu'on fait
c'est comme ça qu'on gère mais il y a
rien qui va dans l'espace allez next
hello Alors en fait je me demandais est
que c'est possible de s'enrumer dans
l'ISS et si jamais c'était le cas en
fait il se passe quoi parce que le virus
doit facilement se refiler et cetera que
vous êtes tous enfermés du coup voilà
merci beaucoup ouais c'est une bonne
question et puis surtout tu sais moi je
suis parti pendant la covid
oua et c'était un vrai souci tu dis
attends si on emmène le virus dans less
tu imagines un peu le combien de test
avant de dans je crois 47 en toutucou ah
ouais donc il y un petit enchaînement de
petit enchaînement non mais pas les
dernières semaines mais tu vois on Fa
des tests tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps et donc un virus dans
l'ISSS bah écoute règle numéro 1 on n
emmène pas donc on est en quarantaine
médicale avant de décoller on est checké
c'est arrivé qu'il y a des décollages
qui soi décalés parce que le gars a une
une petite faringite ou un truc comme ça
quoi il prennent pas de risque Prenn pas
de risque ouais donc on fait ça et à
bord bah tu sais on a des médicaments un
peu normaux tu vois comme tu as chez toi
dans ta pharmacie un peu version quand
même améliorer hôpital de campagne mais
non ça peut arriver que les gens soient
un peu enrumés tu as souvent le nez prix
aussi parce que les fluides se
répartissent différemment mais ouais
ouais règle numéro 1 on emmène pas de
virus euh et puis voilà pour l'instant
ça se passe bien pour l'instant ça va
allez dernière fois next hello Thomas
j'avais une petite question en tête
tuemportes quoi avec toi dans l'ISSS
j'emporte quoi justement ah attends
cette question là on s'est dit tant qu'à
faire on va amener des objets et je te
propose que tu me dises ce qu'on peut
prendre enfin ce que tu peux prendre
plutôt et ce que tu peux pas prendre ok
à bord de à bord de l'ISS petite
sélection d'objets un sac merci ah oui
je les mets dans mon sac carrément
exactement tu vas remplir c'est un
format qui est très populaire sur les
réseaux sociaux un what in my bag ouis
monc voà c'est un peu pareil alors on y
va c'est parti on commence par écoute
par les trucs faciles alors il faut
savoir aussi qu'il y a des choses qui
nous attend là haut tu il y a des choses
qui sont standard et qu'on a pas besoin
d'emmener nous-même donc tu vois
typiquement toute la partie hygiène ça
c'est il y a ce qu'il faut à bord de la
station tu pars avec rien et quand c'est
à bord là un c'est un gel douche comme
nous que tu ch pas du tout ouais c'est
autre chose c'est des tu as des petites
serviettes plibles qui sont dans une une
pochette en aluminium qu'on branche sur
le distributeur d'eau ça les ça les
humidifie un peu elles ont du savon et
après tu déchires ta pochette aluminium
tu sors ta serviette et tu as un truc
humide savonné avec lequel tu te tu te
laves et ensuite tu te tu trinces même
pas vraiment ensuite tu t'essuis avec
une serviette on prend donc ça on prend
pas tu te brosses les dents mais tu bah
c'est pareil tu peux pas cracher de
l'antifrice donc tu tuavales le
dentifrice tu'en mets un petit peu tu te
brosses les dents puis après tu tu bois
un truc et voilà c'est ta petite pastile
de menthe après dîner voilà donc ça
c'est bon on a mis des mouchoirs là
parce que ouais il y a il y a une une
rumeur en tout cas ça circule beaucoup
sur les réseaux sociaux comme quoi tu ne
peux pas pleurer dans l'ISS si tu peux
mais en fait la force qui domine dans
l'ISS c'est la tension de surface la
tension de surface c'est le la force qui
fait coller les liquides au solide et
donc quand tu pleures les les les larmes
vont pas tomber tu vas petit à petit
faire une boule de larme autour de tes
yeux quoi et donc soit tu te secoues la
tête et ça part ou soit tu arrives à les
enlever c'est compliqué quand tu pleures
dans ton scafandre parce que là bah tu
peux pas te toucher les yeux donc les
les mouchoirs il y a peut-être d'autres
choses plus pratiques là-haut l'appareil
photo appareil photo ouais je prends
mais lui il est déjà là
ok aussi donc on va le mettre là ça tu
prends ou pas une écharpe il fait froid
ou pas dans l'ISS non il fait pas froid
en fait c'est compliqué parce que il y a
pas de de sédimentation des gaz tu vois
les l'air chaud monte en sur TER on le
sait les ballons à air chaud et cetera
l'air froid descend tout ça ça se passe
pas ce qui fait qu'il y a pas tellement
de mélange et que tu peux avoir des un
peu des poches de température
différentes à différents endroits et
donc on ventile en permanence pour que
tout ça se mélange mais quand même moi
je trouve qu'il fait en général assez
chaud et il y a pas il y a pas besoin de
ça on laisse bon après moi j'étais en
short tout le temps mais pegy ma
collègue elleelle était tout le temps
avec cinq épaisseurs tu vois donc il a
aussi desouis quand c'est des Italiens
ils ont froid quand c'est tu vois il y a
unu un truc comme ça euh préserv
préservatif non écoute enfin je sais pas
du moins nous dans notre équipage on en
a pas beso un sac de couchage comment
onor dans l'ISSS et ben il est déjà
là-haut aussi tu vois mais on dort dans
un sac de couchage avec des trous pour
les bras qui est accroché au mur enfin
qui peut être accroché n'importe où au
plafond au mur à l'envers par terre dans
une petite cabine et donc tu te glisses
dedans tu le zipes tu dors comme ça
souvent se moi je me collais bien à la
paroi avec un un tendeur tu vois en
travers du corps parce que tu as besoin
de cette sensation un peu physique de
d'écrasement de reposer sur quelque
chose sinon c'est difficile vraiment de
de dormir quand tu flottes complètement
tu te tu te détends pas parce que sur
terre ça existe pas tu es pas encore
habitué alors ça oui parce que ça un peu
régressif tu repenses à Monsieur Capel
quand tu pu c'est des trucs de mon
enfant même encore avant tu vois mais
mais ça ça veut dire qu'on peut emmener
bah de la nourriture un peu au choix
dans la station en plus du standard qui
encore une fois nous attend déjà là-haut
alors pour avoir des on va dire des
biscuits français la NASA il ils ont un
peu galéré mais mais bon c'était sympa
c'était des petits clin d'œil tu vois
chacun ses petits trucs soit qui leur
appppelle leur enfance qui leur rappelle
je sais pas quelque chose d'autre et ça
tu c'est à la fraise ça fa forcément des
BAT mais on F pas ouais oui c'est vrai
ouais ouais ça on est on n pas prêt des
Times alors ça j'avais lu une anecdote
sur soi-disant des timbes qui étaient
interdit de interdiction de les emmener
ouais ou ça peut prendre de la valeur et
certains essayer de de le faire c'est ça
c'est l' mission Apollo je crois que
c'est Apollo 15 qui était une super
mission mais les gars les pauvres tous
ceux dont on leur parle depuis toujours
depuis des dizaines d'années c'est qui
sont emené des j' met une couche
aujourd'hui c'est ça et oui ils avaient
mené des timbres il les avaient revendu
à des collectionneurs pour une une somme
qui était même pas super élevée tu sais
à l'époque et depuis a des règles qui
disent qu'on a pas le droit d'emmener de
des devises des timbres et chaque fois
qu'on emmène un objet par exemple pour
nos proches tu leur fais signer un
papier disant qu'il s'engage à pas le
vendre que tu redonnes à la NASA après
très bien le le julver ouais le julver
on l'emmène parce qu'il avait tout
compris avant les autres alors on lit
plutôt sur tablette tu imagines parce
que si on s'emmène ça à chaque fois dans
l'espace mais avant il y avait même une
espèce de petite bibliothèque dans la
station spatiale qui était pas grande
mais les gens quimené un bouquin ou deux
ils le laissaient et et tuavait une
bibliothèque mais je crois qu'on a
acheté à la poubelle depuis
malheureusement mais on emmène si tu
retourne tias
mettre celui-ici ou alors ou sur la lune
qui sait pourquoi pas une petite
bibliothèque comme ça sur la lune tu
viens déposer prendre un livre ton sac
est prêttir finement prêt allez c'est
parti il faudra un tout petit peu plus
que ça mais bon on son occupé avec les
agences ça va aller merci beaucoup je
t'en prie merci à toi cétait top à
bientôt peut-être et puis on te souhaite
le meilleur pour pour la suite on suivra
tout ça merci allez merci beaucoupci
beaucoup ouais je t'en prie merci top
intéressant vous êtes venu juste pour ça
alors et voilà là là
untit tu as commencé à dire monsieur
Capel j'ai fait oh là là j'ai AR para
tutais tu marchais
sur des façons de lancerag tout le monde
SAU vraiment ce
mec hier on s posé la question on s dit
si je te lance sur les prof tu s un truc
ene non un prof particuli pas de
prof se comm merci becoup mer beaucoup à
bientôtci beaucoupci pr temp merci
beaucoup
salut